PROFESSOR: We have now expressed
in terms of the energy density
on this mode omega
I the contribution
to the transition amplitude.
The fact that all these
modes act incoherently
means that each one has a shot
in producing the transition.
And the probabilities
now must be added.
So the way to sum probabilities
now is the following.
If you have a sum over I of this
frequency sum I of some energy
density u of I times
any function of omega I,
you can replace it by
an integral d omega.
Instead of little omega
I's that you're summing,
you now integrate
over omega the energy
density of your radiation field
times the function of omega.
So instead of having
a sum of these things,
you now integrate over
a continuous variable.
And this represents the
energy density in the range.
This whole thing is
the energy density
in the range d omega,
which is in that range d
omega, the energy range.
The energy density is the
sum of the energy densities
of each of the contributions.
So that's what we're going to
do here to express and to get
our transition amplitude.
So we'll say that we have
the sum over I of Pab I of t
equals 8 pi over h squared
integral u of omega d omega dab
and omega sine squared of
1/2 omega ba minus omega t.
So all the omega I's
have become omegas.
That's the variable
of integration.
And this is information
about your radiation field.
If it's a black body radiation,
we gave the formula last time.
So this is your
transition amplitude.
And we have to try
to do the integral.
This one I that remained here.
So what do we have to do now?
Well, is it, again, the
kind of useful story?
We know that this factor
from Fermi's golden rule
tends to say, basically, you
get only the contribution
from omegas equal to omega ba.
So whatever else is
being integrated,
nothing varies as fast as this.
And you can take it out of
the integral approximating
omega for omega ba.
So that is a little
more delicate here.
So I'll just write
an equality here.
So it's 8 pi over h squared.
I'll take the u at omega ba out
of the integral, this factor.
And I want to take
this one out as well.
But this one is a little funny.
As I change the omega,
the polarization
of this electric field is going
to come in all directions.
It's going to come at random.
So even for a given
frequency omega,
there might be many
modes of frequency omega
that are coming at the particle
at different directions.
And that's exactly
what I would expect
for thermal radiation,
which is truly
the case we're doing here,
incoherence superposition
of light.
So when I have this, and
I integrate over omegas,
the various omegas,
even for a given omega,
there might be many
lines that correspond
to just a different direction.
Because the field comes
in all directions.
So the interpretation is
that we can take this out,
but we must do an average
over all directions of omega.
So this factor will
go out as dab dot n.
But here, we will average
over all directions of n.
And it's a square here.
So this is important because the
field comes in all directions.
We've taken care of this.
Then, finally, we
have the integral,
the omega of the sine squared
function a minus omega.
All right.
So a couple of things
still remain to be done.
One thing that I don't think
we need to do explicitly
again is this integral.
We've done it a couple of times.
You do a change of variables.
The t will go out
linearly, and this
becomes an integral of sine
squared over x squared,
which is equal to pi.
And so this integral has
been done a couple of times.
Let me just write the answer to
this thing is 1/2 t times pi.
It's linear in t.
That we've observed.
And it's pretty important
that it's linear in t
because that means that
the probability-- you know,
we've been writing this thing--
the probability of transition
is linear in time.
Therefore, you
can divide by time
to get that rate of transition.
So we're almost there.
Let's put this together.
We have this is the sum of P's.
And there's this t there.
So the transition
rate, W from b to a
is this probability
divided by time.
So it's going to
cancel this time.
Then the 2 is going to give a 4.
The pi is going to
give a pi squared.
There's going to
be an h squared.
There's going to be this
factor dab dot n squared.
And there's going to
be the u of omega ba.
So this is going to be the rate.
We've divided by t, the previous
result. And there we have it.
We're almost finished
with the calculation.
The rate is here.
The only difficulty
here is this average,
but it is not complicated,
in fact, doing this average.
It's actually kind of simple.
So let's do it.
So what is it?
It's all the matter of
writing things properly here.
There's the average
of dab dot n squared.
So this is the average of dab
dot n complex conjugate times
dab dot n.
So it's good to do this
thing because, actually, you
have to face as to what
these symbols really mean.
dab is a vector with
complex components.
Electric field is a vector,
but it has real components.
dab is a vector.
Why is it a vector?
Because it has a
vector index here.
It really came from this
operator over there d is qr.
So it's x, y, and z.
And each one has matrix
elements between states a and b.
And with matrix elements
between states a
and b that are complex
wave functions,
this can be complex numbers.
So in general, this dab
is a complex vector.
And the star is necessary here.
So, this is a number.
This, however, is a number.
And I took the number star
times the number and average.
So the dot products
can be written as sums.
So I'll put here a sum
over I and a sum over j.
dab, the ith component
times ni, the ith component.
Here, this should be star.
And that's the sum over i
is the first dot product.
dabj and j, the sum over j
is the second dot product.
These d's are numbers, so
they don't have anything
to do with the average
that we're doing
over different directions.
So we have i and j of
di ab star dj ab times
the average of ni nj.
This average, if you wish,
you could simply do it.
If you don't want to
use symmetry arguments
to do an average like
that, you take a vector,
parameterize it
with theta and phi
and just do the integral
over solid angle.
And divide by 4 pi.
This should give
you the same answer.
If you're uncomfortable with
what we're going to say now,
you should do that
because that average just
means take the vector
n, integrate it
over all directions, all
solid angles, and average.
So what is this ni nj?
I claim this thing
is 1/3 delta ij.
And it's based on
the following idea,
that the average
between nx and ny,
by the time you integrate
over the sphere, is 0.
The average of off diagonal
things don't have averages.
nx with nx, however,
would have an average
because it's always positive.
ny with ny would have an average
And nz with nz would
have an average.
And each one of these
three would be the same
because there's no real
difference between the x, y,
and z directions.
And therefore, you
have three things.
And at the end of the day,
this average of nx and x
plus ny and y plus nz
and z is this average
of n squared, which
is equal to 1.
So it should be equal to 1.
So that each one of these
nx, nx, or ny, ny, or nz, nz
must add up to a total of 1.
Therefore, this is the 1/3.
So that's what this is.
And if you find
this a little funny,
you should do the integral and
then think about this argument
again.
So anyway, that's the answer.
And therefore, we get 1/3.
And the delta ij
establishes a dot product
between these two things.
So this is dab vector star
dotted with the dab vector.
This is a vector complex
conjugated because we said
the components can be complex.
So that's the answer.
And most people like
to just simply write it
as dab vector squared like that.
But this is not just the
vector dotted with itself.
It's a vector dotted with
its complex conjugate.
So with this number, the
whole formula is now finished.
This is the final form.
The rate for
spontaneous transition
triggered by
electromagnetic fields,
an incoherent superposition
of electromagnetic fields
is 4 pi squared.
We get the 1/3 here
over 3h squared.
dab vector squared u omega ba.
And it's a transition
rate per atom.
We've considered a single atom.
So it's transition
rate per atom.
All right.
Long derivation, but a
lot of physics in it.
A transition between
discrete state
got convoluted with an
integral of the stimuli
as it comes in and produce
a nice result in the style
of Fermi's golden rule.
Griffiths called that
Fermi golden rule.
He works with Si units.
And there's epsilon zeros
and different numbers of pi's
there.
I'm sorry.
With checked.
This is consistent, and we
can't do much about that.